walk down the right back alley in Sin
City and you can find anything except
for tickets at the box office watch the
[ __ ] movie sin city a dame to whoa
the show is raw now Sin City is one of
my all-time favorite movies hands down
one of the best cineplex experiences
I've ever had right next to when I got a
hand job from this hot italian / jewish
chick kind i had a big nose but it
wasn't a [ __ ] it was a hand so i
could imagine her where the smaller nose
but whatever we're going out of here
after films like 300 and watchmen I knew
adapting a film and like pure comic book
style form would not be as appealing as
it once was when I saw the trailer for
this movie I was still like ready to
[ __ ] and piss my pants and even vomit a
little bit and honestly after work out
of this movie I wouldn't say I'm
disappointed but I would say it was a
little let down I know that might sound
like the same thing but whatever it's my
choice of words [ __ ] you it's pretty
difficult for me to take this film on
its own merits and not compare it to the
first one honestly I feel like if I
didn't even see the first one I probably
still have the same kind of issues the
film just seems to like in life it seems
to like in spirit you guys remember that
movie the spirit no one does me no good
me wrong the visuals are still fantastic
they're still beautiful to look at the
3d was [ __ ] awesome plus Eva greens
tits in 3d whoa [ __ ] you know I thought
her tits in 3d was awesome at three and
reserve an empire we get way more boob
action in this one and wow just you like
get so many shots of her boobs in 3d you
just stare at them and start to examine
them and just be like I know the exact
shape of her boobs and you remember that
like even my girlfriend was watching
with me and she was like damn to a child
was like I know you should have tits
like her one day to where she walked out
of the theater haven't heard from her in
a few days still waiting on that phone
call baby hope you're watching the
visuals they quickly stopped being
enticing and the movie just lacks some
personality it's weird cuz the stories
are all different yet the tone
style feel all exactly the same it's
serious Phil minutes it's more serious
than it is fun that's where the person
city was so awesome the four stories
felt very different the characters felt
different but her personalities were
more to find they were more
distinguished and the film itself kind
of have like a romantic theme about it
that was really felt it was just a true
love letter to the comics where the
emotion was really captured this one
felt like Frank Miller Rodriguez weren't
immersing us into the world they were
kind of just photographing it and the
way they structure these stories and how
to tell them I didn't really care for it
was obvious they were trying to have the
stories trying more than how the
previous film had them tie in and but it
kind of worked against the movie like it
starts off with marv and it's cool
because it's barb and it's exciting to
see him again they established his story
but they never bring the story back and
never wrap up a story there's really no
point to that story I mean Mickey Rourke
is marv still [ __ ] solid the guys
that he's Marv Marvin this movie kind of
felt like he was just there because we
liked him in the last one it was just
like whenever a main character needed
help they would call on mark it lacks
sense of danger and suspense because we
knew Marv would still be alive because
this is a prequel so no mean he's gonna
be alive it really makes you like okay I
guess we're just gonna sit back and
watch mark kill people like Mickey
Rourke was bringing his you know marred
game to the table but the way he was
captured he didn't feel like anything
special in this film but I must say I
have one complaint about this franchise
that deals with Marv in the first sin
city he has sex with this really
good-looking hooker named Goldie I don't
care if you sell your body for money I
don't care how desperate you are to
survive your [ __ ] would never get wet
for someone who looked like that there
are plenty of women who do not get wet
for me okay so everything getting away
from me hey away for this guy ago then
we see Johnny played by Joseph
gordon-levitt let's just establish
something up from let's get something
clear if a movie looks like [ __ ] but you
see Joseph gordon-levitt's in it you're
like movies probably gonna be good in
someone jiggles the [ __ ] man [ __ ] that
JGL crap jiggle that sounds way cooler
subject jelly this was my favorite story
out of the whole film from my
understanding it was written
specifically for the movie
google is awesome as Johnny he's back
being suave and sexy and gordon-levitt
way he's an awesome poker player and now
to me this story had the most life to it
johnny was very different from the other
stories like there was some great poker
scenes to watch exploring johnny was
really cool and the story itself doesn't
have that much violence yet when the
violence is there is very impactful it's
cringe-worthy as opposed to the other
stories where they have plenty of gore
but you kind of become numb to it he was
the only character in this film that was
truly invested in then we see Nancy
again and i gotta say jessica alba's
performance as Nancy Callahan was ten
times like 50 times better than it was
in the first sin city I mean starts off
with her and she's back as a stripper
and it's been like 10 years and I still
jerk off to her she sees Hartigan
everywhere she goes who wants revenge
against work and it's the last story
they conclude and want you to go from
bad ass stripper too late he mentions
was pretty [ __ ] sweet me I don't know
how she got so good at murdering a bunch
of people she gets a crossbow and she's
like perfect at it but whatever the
weird thing about it is Hartigan's in
the story played by [ __ ] celebrity
Bruce Willis you hear Hartigan's
internal monologue even though he's dead
but then so it must be coming from
Nancy's mind but you also hear Nancy's
internal monologue so it's like it's
hard to get a ghost you're like nah just
split personality but then they do
something at the end of the story we're
like wait a min starting a ghost I like
the idea of Hartigan like still haunting
Nancy soul but it sort of felt like they
knew they had Bruce Willis back so they
should do more with him but they kind of
throw and stuff that just ended up
confusing me or they helped me to the
real nits and grits of the Nancy story
look at Scarface it hops into the Dwight
story the dame to kill for a story
here's my problem because a bit of Marv
a bit of Johnny a bit of Nancy in like a
whole hour of Dwight and he honestly had
the least interesting story which sucks
because this is the dame to kill her
story I mean this is Dwight before he
got the surgery before he looked like
Clive omen I mean Josh Brolin I love is
one of my favorite actors out there he's
great at playing badasses and I've seen
his ass in movies he's got a badass yeah
he's perfectly cast for this role okay
and everyone's been talking about the
dame to kill for it believe the hype Eva
Green really does steal the show she's
seductive she has an innocence about her
again she's a total [ __ ] [ __ ] I don't
want to get near her but same time we
come
I put your penis inside of her same time
she has like an old school in the water
performance yeah you feel like she get
dirty [ __ ] really hardcore like
modern-day pawn they're just incredible
amounts of life to her performance and
it made the story like really worth
watching it the performances weren't
really good I probably wouldn't have
cared much for it because it's sort of
like they just capture the pages instead
of truly feeling the emotion behind it
it could have been a really strong like
tragic romance story but instead it
moves fast getting kind of boring at
times it's strange how it's like it's
all there but my heart was the same
feeling it and when Dwight finally gets
a surgery and he's supposed to look like
the Clive Owen version was just kind of
weird because it's like they just ask
live I want to make a cameo I mean only
clive owens that busy I mean going me
wrong there's still some fantastic
sequences in this movie there's still
great acting throughout but it just
didn't grasp me the wish I felt it Nick
should have you know yeah I mean
Horrocks I felt just doesn't have as
much personality as it could have but
still there's enough sweet things for me
to say let me get straight to the boy
here all i gotta say sin city a dame to
kill for got it for the most part right
alright guys thanks chicken on review
for sin city a dame to kill for why
don't you go ahead screw that comment
box below and tell me what celebrity
female do you think has the best titties
if you guys want to follow me on twitter
or any other social network [ __ ] let's
do it and last but not least if you
wanna get updated every time one of my
reviews or videos is out going to clear
his blood about my dig to subscribe
that's right the Didache let me tell you
something about this little center he
has so many Danes that are willing to
kill for a moment of his done punch that